hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcasts vitamin D is a modifier
of genomic function and phenotypic
expression during pregnancy presented by
Bruce Hollis he is a professor of
pediatrics biochemistry and molecular
biology he is also the director of
pediatric nutritional sciences at
Medical University of South Carolina
I am Marjorie Torres of labrys and I'll
be your moderator for today's event we
are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
Lackey's laggards is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the green Q&A button located in the
lower left of the presentation window
and type your questions into the box
that appears on the screen will answer
as many of your questions as we have
time for at the end of the presentation
also please notice that you'll be
viewing the presentation in the slide
window to enlarge the window just click
on the screen icon located on the lower
right if you have trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation please click on
the support button at the top right of
the presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem this presentation is
educational and that's uppers continuing
education credits please click on the
button in the bottom left corner and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Bruce Hollis I will now turn the
presentation over to him
thank you very much the honor to speak
at this I've done it a couple other
times but the data keep getting newer
and newer so I come back to do it more
again so today I want to talk about
vitamin D as a modifier of genomic
function and phenotypic expression
during pregnancy during the early days
of I'll move on here I have I have
nothing to disclose so during the early
days when studies were looked at for
vitamin D and pregnancy a lot of
misconceptions came from those from
those studies in fact there was a lot of
paranoia about them and a lot of this
started after World War two and took
place in in England where they where
they were supplementing vitamin D and
they noticed what they thought was a
connection between vitamin D giving
during pregnancy and hypocalcemic
episodes which were basically attributed
to vitamin D at the time and then they
got paranoid about giving vitamin D
during the during the prenatal or
perinatal period so it came to an abrupt
halt the problem is what they were
looking at at that time was a condition
called Williams syndrome which had
nothing to do with vitamin D during
pregnancy they they figured this how
around the mid 70s and and and that that
it wasn't a problem but the problem that
happened was once they made this
Association in the 50s and then in the
60s they started doing experimental
animal work with high doses of vitamin D
and rabbits and they were inducing
something that they said was a aortic
stenosis syndrome in these animals and a
lot of work and it was published
actually by NIH
and in stein teen 68 a dr. Friedman at
NIH actually who was a pathologist
published a paper called vitamin D is
the cause of aortic stenosis syndrome
and that basically was a death knell of
vitamin D Huez during pregnancy and that
has been carried forward even to this
day and a lot of obstetrics and
gynaecology people are scared to death
of vitamin D because these
misconceptions unfortunately still
permeate professional organizations
this is disproven it's not an issue but
we still have to deal with this so the
first thing that you notice about
vitamin D and vitamin D is associated
with the course is calcium metabolism
and abnormal bone growth and it was the
first thing that was recognized and
oftentimes the first thing is recognized
with the given causative agent is the
only thing that it from that point forth
that it does and that's been a problem
with vitamin D is that when you talk
about the things I'm going to talk about
in the future you come back to this well
it's really not important because a
vitamin D Mannino is only a bone factor
and so it can't possibly have an effect
on on these other issues that you're
talking about and so if we come back to
the skeletal problems skeletal problems
even with this infant Lauren is called
craziest Hades where it's severe vitamin
D deficiency in utero and the bone the
fontanelles you'll see don't close at
Birth and it's abnormal unfortunately
this isn't that rare and as this paper
and shows in a Japanese study and the
good news here is that that this will
resolve okay when you initiate vitamin D
supplementation in nutrition after birth
the other problems that I'm going to
talk about are not so lucky
such as
asthma in the newborn child or
preeclampsia or other complications of
birth that there tributed to vitamin D
and here we see the classic formation of
rickets again we come back to the the
function of vitamin D that so many
people think is the only one and you'll
see on the left the the girl that has
vitamin D deficiency both legs or kid at
grocery because of growth plates are not
functioning in this individual because
of vitamin D deficiency and when they're
and when they're repleted with vitamin D
you can see that the that the condition
is corrected and the individual looks
normal in can go on at least from a
skeletal standpoint and live a fairly
normal life so how here we come back to
the question is and this was a question
that's that still wrestled with today is
that how do you know what a normal
vitamin D level would be and when I talk
about a normal vitamin D level I'm
talking about the circulating 25 hydroxy
vitamin D because that's the the
compound that gives you the nutritional
vitamin D status it's the compound is
measured when you go to your physician
and they said we want to measure the
vitamin D content they measure 25
hydroxy vitamin D as a long half-life in
the blood and it gives you the
indication of how much vitamin D you
have it's not really quite that simple
but it's it's the best marker we have
for assessing vitamin D status and I'll
go back to this really important paper
in JCM in 1971 published by dr. Haddad
and Chu where in this paper the doctor
had died develop the first really good
valid method to measure vitamin D 25
hydroxy vitamin D in individuals and
this was done in st. Louis and they went
and collected what they called normal
volunteers
billiard biliary cirrhosis patients who
have fat malabsorption and vitamin D is
a fat-soluble vitamin so they they have
pathi sighs it would be low in these
people and then they went and got
lifeguards why did they get lifeguards
well lifeguards spend a lot of time in
the Sun and as everybody knows the Sun
is an integral part sun exposure is an
integral part of forming vitamin D in
animals in fact it's really the only way
that we get vitamin D others in
supplementation because vitamin D
doesn't really exist in a normal diet we
put it there in and say milk products
and butter but if from a natural
standpoint it doesn't exist in our diet
we're dependent on sun exposure and sun
exposure in our society today is is it's
not used very much because of cancer
paranoia and use of Sun creams and and
and such is that so let's come back to
the normal volunteer so normal
volunteers in this case would have been
people who work in offices physicians
whoever they could find who were quote
normal living the normal life and
probably didn't spend a lot of time in
the Sun had a normal normal diet and
when they measured these individuals the
level came out to around 27 nanograms
per ml biliary cirrhosis patients were
much lower not surprising and the
lifeguards were two-and-a-half to three
times higher than a quote normal
individuals were than the normal
individuals so if they would have if
they would have interpreted this data in
a more robust fashion okay they would
have determined that the lifeguards here
where it's a normal level that's the
level that people should have a try to
attain and their reasons why this never
happened okay and you go back to the
even
okay so the normal volunteer it's not
that hard to get to 27 nanograms but if
you want to get to 64 nanograms you
either do it by a lot of sun exposure or
by taking substantial amounts of vitamin
D supplements and by substantial I need
to get to an oral dose to get to where
these lifeguards in but has to be a dose
of between four to six thousand IU's per
day of vitamin D now that you'd go back
to 1971 if somebody would have come out
and said at the time well our daily
requirement of vitamin D should be for
the six thousand units it didn't jive
with what the recommendations were and
so they believed their recommendations
more than they believed the physiology
and that was part of the problem so we
went forth with normal volunteers that
at low levels when in fact they should
have been two lifeguards because the
regulator's just weren't ready to
grapple with it and even today they're
really not so and the reason being is
that people had this misconception of
how toxic vitamin D was to come back to
1997 the first recommendations by the
Institute of Medicine they made this
statement the 2,000 units of vitamin D
per day was the safest level that you
could take without getting
hypervitaminosis D in high blood calcium
the problem was that this statement was
grossly in air and was an impediment to
health to the healthy human beings and
it was derived from I can only describe
as absolutely dreadful data that was
that was published in an obscure journal
from India that never should have made
its way into it any sort of publication
yet alone taken and and recommendations
made from it and just to highlight this
2000 dose of vitamin D simply isn't
enough to do anything I mean given the
fact that a day in the Sun but from an
individual light-skinned individual they
will make ten to twenty thousand units
not given day so it's it never made
sense to me how you could have 2,000
units a day be harmful and in fact it's
not the latest ul Satan by the Institute
of Medicine I think was arbitrarily set
at 4,000 units per day which is better
than 2,000 but where this number came
from is is really quite a mystery in in
2010 when they said it and we had done
studies in and in fact had an
institutional or a drug application
where we were okay to give four thousand
units and the studies I'm going to talk
about and so maybe they took that from
that I don't know the truth is intakes
of 10,000 units a day are totally safe
and used routinely and so there's no
harm in taking that much vitamin D the
2010 Institute of Medicine position
which is official government
recommendation to do this
the Institute of Medicine reported in
the 2010 report that the optimal
circulating level that vitamin D was 50
nano molar or 20 nanograms it's the same
number if it's you're reporting in in
animals you have to divide that number
by two and a half to get nanograms per
ml the IOM states that stated that a
level of greater than 125 nano moles 50
nano grams are potentially harmful and
this statement is especially odd
considering that humans evolved in a
nature in nature from millenniums were
25 level far exceeded 50 nanograms per
ml so how did the Institute of Medicine
come to this
well the 20 nanograms was basically
recommended solely from skeletal
interactions the Institute of Medicine
basically at that time said look all
were all we believe that vitamin D has
an effect on is skeleton all these other
things cancer pregnancy that I'm going
to talk about hasn't been proven that
vitamin D is important in those things
though we're not going to make any
recommendations based on observational
study zone during randomized can
trials for which they were several for
bone and not many for anything else but
that second one were a level of 15
anagrams was recommended they broke
their own rule and used some
observational data that stated that
levels above 15 anagrams may be
inductive of of prostate cancer which
again was a dreadful study and they
broke their own rules by using an
observational study to make a
recommendation a harmful or a you know
potentially harmful recommendation that
makes no sense from Physiology yet they
wouldn't use it to make other
recommendations that have a lot more
basis in science you also have to be
aware of how vitamin D is dosed can can
have profound outcomes on studies how
the study comes out and by that I mean
vitamin D has been dosed over many years
either by vitamin D by a daily dose
vitamin D by a weekly dose vitamin D by
a monthly dose or every two months or
every three months or every six months
or even one study gave it once a year
now
common sense tells you that that that's
probably not the best way to do things
daily would be the best followed by
followed by weekly and beyond that and
again these studies were all based on
skeletal skeletal in interactions and
not the other things that we're going to
talk about you have to be real careful
about how you dose vitamin D in a given
study now this this just to highlight
this this paper was published recently
by Adrian Martin oh and they were
looking at how supplementation to
prevent acute respiratory tract
infections or how the dosing effected
the results of a given study so you can
you can go get this paper and read it if
you like but I'm going to go to the next
slide and this is a figure Table two in
martinel study and you look at the read
sir
on this paper and you read down the
right side it says dosing dosing regime
okay the first one it says bolus dose of
greater than 3000 I use given bolus dose
means it was given in one single dose in
a week or a month or whatever they did
to mimic and then to mimic how much they
got in a given time there were ten ten
trials that did that and then under that
is bolus dose not giving which would
mean a daily dose of vitamin B and then
how did that affect study outcomes so if
you looked under the p-value you can see
if it's fun on infections acute
respiratory infections if it was given
an a bolus dose it failed to be
effective p-value of 0.05 seven however
if it was given as a daily dose and I'm
sorry but that numbers covered up it was
significant at a very high level meaning
that if it was given on a daily dose it
was effective for preventing infections
were or a bolus dose were not so if you
go beyond skeleton and dosing I think
that that you that have to be really
careful about how you give vitamin D and
the reason that they would give bolus
dosing is if for convenience they they
would feel but study people would
conceal that it would be more compliant
if people took it once a week or once a
month as opposed to every day but when
it's going to infect your study outcomes
you really have to and so this has been
one of the major confusions on all these
studies published vitamin D works for
this it doesn't work for this a lot of
it has to come down to how it was dosed
in a given study and this slide is
complicated and you can though we see
this slide and where it was published in
Journal of Clinical Endocrinology and
metabolism by myself and Carol Wagner a
few years back and it's explained better
in that paper that I can do here I could
spend the whole time just explaining
this figure
you have vitamin D you enter in either
from diet or sun exposure on the left
there the halftime of vitamin E in a
circulation is very quick it comes and
goes very quickly if you look right
below it you'll see the end of
proportion of the vitamin D system which
everybody knows and that's what we've
been taught for four decades and it's
the one that functions through skeletal
integrity where vitamin D is metabolized
at 25 D and then it's metabolized in the
kidney so they act a hormonal form of
125 and then it goes about it's put back
into the circulation from the kidney and
then acts as an endocrine portion
primarily to handle skeletal health the
one that is not talked about and
functions is equally important and is
coming to light is would be a paracrine
and endocrine function and that would be
on the right in that orange circle where
vitamin d itself would would diffuse
into given tissues breast colon can't
whatever okay and it would go into those
tissues where within those cells it can
be activated by the enzymes present to
the active form of 125 and then go about
its function of controlling gene
suppression activation whatever and it's
known that vitamin D first of all the
receptors for the hormonal form of
vitamin D the 125 are located almost in
every tissue in the body and also in in
a lot of those tissues those tissues
have the ability to activate vitamin D
in a parent or inter conform to use them
within a given cell to control gene
function how many genes are there that
could be affected by vitamin D well
given give or take about 10 percent of
all our genes around 2,000 genes have
vitamin D response elements in the
control region that somehow respond to
vitamin D and a positive or negative
fashion so it's it's vast and very few
of those jeans have anything to do with
calcium homeostasis so now we move into
the public health and the world need of
the this presentation about a public
health issue and deficiency of vitamin D
during pregnancy we first got interested
and I've been interested in it for four
decades but you really couldn't do any
meaningful work until about the year
2000 because you couldn't get meaningful
amounts of vitamin D to a pregnant woman
or pretty much any other person when the
Institute of Medicine said that 2,000
units or more was harmful you couldn't
get this the studies through an
institutional review board or an NIH
study section because they would fall
back and say well you can't do this
because you're gonna hurt the patient
when in fact those recommendations
weren't even enough okay and so we
instituted dr. Wagner and I instituted
these studies in in 2000 wrote a grant
set at the NIH we wanted to determine
what the true requirement of vitamin D
in pregnancy is based on skeletal
function and also how much vitamin D it
would take to normalize 25 hydroxy
vitamin D in a pregnant woman we said
the normal level should be 30 nanograms
or 75 nanomoles per ml how much would it
take to get in there so we we went to
the drawing board we wrote up a grant
sent at the NIH and we wanted to give up
to 4,000 units of vitamin D per day to
these women now this is this is a decade
or more ago okay even 15 years ago so
the NIH thought it was a great study
that the study sections thought it was a
great study but when it came back to and
they funded the project when they came
back to our institution predictably it
went to the institutional review board
and they said wait a minute wait a
minute
you have to we will not let you do this
study because you're your
ten times the amount that the
professional societies say is necessary
and we just can't allow this you have to
go to the Food and Drug Administration
to get their their their permission to
do this and so we sent an application to
the Food and Drug Administration which
is called a non exempt IND which is a
couple of pages and you fill out and
then they say yes go ahead with the
study which we anticipated but what they
said was no they said you have to write
a full investigation a drug application
before we will allow you to do this
study what that meant was we spent the
next six months writing up this is what
drug companies have to do to do drug
studies writing up an investigational
drug application with vitamin D proving
to the FDA that we were not going to
hurt anybody and so we wrote it up and
lo and behold about six to eight months
later and FDA awarded us our IND you can
see at the bottom of this thing it was
the first ever awarded to investigation
for a vitamin you know they do this for
drug so that's how paranoid they were
about about assessing or giving giving a
study anyway the study went forth it was
a randomized controlled double-blind
placebo study basically women it's
approximately sixteen weeks when they
came in to discover they were pregnant
were randomized and put on the study in
this first study there were all sorts of
safety recommendations I mean it was
being monitored by the NIH was being
monitored by her institutional review
board was being monitored by the Food
and Drug Administration for any adverse
events that we would see in any of these
women so it was very expensive in very
time-consuming
you can look this paper was published in
2011 in the journal Bone and Mineral
Research but it's been cited 500 times
it's one of the most cited papers during
the time now that in in this period it
continues to be a landmark paper and if
you want to go and read it it's very
long and is very detailed
and you can read everything that we did
in that study and basically it basically
it was a also beyond that it was a
safety study are we gonna did anybody
get hurt from doing this the the short
answer is we saw not a single adverse
event in any of these women do the
vitamin D supplementation when we looked
at what was required to normalize
vitamin B to the level that we wanted
the groups were 400 units 2,000 units or
4,000 units per day took seven years to
complete this study when we looked at it
we saw know of no event adverse event
due to vitamin D supplementation
it was quite unremarkable for anything
skeletal eyes because basically in this
population these women were really not
vitamin D deficient enough to see any
and unlike if you look at what the level
should be the skeletal system in the
endocrine system requires not as much
vitamin D as these other things like
infection there are two separate systems
one to end upon one's parent in
immigrant so when you're talking about
what the normal level should be you
really need to skeleton not much and
other things a prevention of the things
that I'm going to talk about
preeclampsia asmin children that's a
different story
you need more but when we finally finish
his study and and we broke down data we
collected a lot of data okay you have to
keep in mind it's the things that I'm
going to show you now we're secondary
analysis because in 2000 he had no idea
that vitamin D would function beyond in
any of these things so when we looked at
it in an intent to treat here on
secondary analysis long behold if you
look in the blue numbers on there we
found what they had been finding in some
observational studies we found decrease
in cesarean sections decrease
significant decrease due to vitamin D
supplementation and complication
pregnancy comorbidities and and you can
see now how is this received in the
community at large and basically I will
tell you that they thought we were
insane this couldn't possibly be true it
was presented at a meeting and it was
really a it was really a lively
conversation with the people that were
there classic skull people when they saw
this data they just would not believe it
so how effective is vitamin D at
reducing the the say complications of
pregnancy well in the study that I
showed you that we did we didn't have
really severe vitamin D deficiency and
so the the the studies were were
interesting but not remarkable I this
study that I'm showing you from this
graph was published in Clinical
Endocrinology a couple of years ago was
done in India where we couldn't do this
study in the US because these patients
coming in in the first trimester were
profoundly vitamin D deficient and they
were left like that in our in our
country if a woman now comes in in a
study and they are profoundly deficient
you cannot you can't give them nothing
you have to give them standard of care
which is four to six hundred units a day
by the governing organization so they
get something in India they get they
didn't have to give him anything so what
they did was they had a placebo group
that got nothing and they were Pro
finally vitamin D deficient and then
they had vitamin D supplemented groups
where they gave a substantial amount of
vitamin D and they monitor complications
of pregnancy and when they supplemented
these women they found a profound
decrease in complications of pregnancy
was astounding look at that graph so
there was no question that vitamin D
would have it but this is extra skeletal
list preterm labor gestational diabetes
and all things to go along with
complications of pregnancy so it was
clear that vitamin D
was associated with these things so
let's talk about preterm birth alright
it's one of the things that we've looked
at now and over the last several years
once we determined that vitamin D had
these effects beyond skeleton so this
study we've looked at several different
studies now we've looked at the original
NIH study we had another study called
with the Thrasher group Thresher funded
funded some of our pregnancy research we
the Kellogg Foundation funded research
and we've looked at this in several
publications now on several studies and
what this graph shows is by vitamin D
status how much preterm birth is
associated with circulating 25 when when
these children are born and the mothers
levels and you look at this graph and it
doesn't look very remarkable but you see
that that gestational you know
gestational age goes up as 25 hydroxy
levels in creeks are higher in the
pregnant women so let's expand this to a
different highlight the area and you can
see that the this the gestational age
increases as these women go up to the
point where about 40 nanograms per ml
seems the spot where you at least want
to be during pregnancy to prevent
complications of pregnancy or preterm
birth and that's what we saw from our
early data 14 anagrams give or take is
really the the level that you want to be
at during pregnancy now these were done
these were dot these were done during
pregnancy not not at not when somebody
was pregnant they already got pregnant
conception and here's another view of
that graph again these these studies are
published by myself and dr. Wagner and
other investigators you can go on Club
metod you can find these publications
and you can read them so this is the
hazard ratio so as your vitamin D level
increases your hazard of a preterm birth
Goes Down so of course when when you're
doing research like that other people's
other people take notice of it and that
we had been given an institutional I
indeed to study vitamin D we were
approached by a lot of people to do
other studies and I think the most
interesting one of all was done when the
Harvard group of Scott wise and Gus
Latonia contacted us in 2007 with this
idea that vitamin D supplementation
during pregnancy might decrease the
asthma rates in children after birth
meaning you'd give vitamin D to the
pregnant woman there's going to be
changes initiated in utero that will
help children not get asthma after
they're born okay so the V dart study
was born vitamin D vitamin D anti-natal
as no reduction trial it was a huge
study it was done at three sites
clinical sites one in Boston one in st.
Louis one in San Diego it was a huge
study it cost millions of dollars to do
it's still ongoing today and there's
been an incredible amount of data that
was generated from this and so we were
part of this and still remain part of
this today so what what have we found in
Wyson and Latonia here found from the
from the V dart trial well the
hypothesis was vitamin D supplementation
the mother during pregnancy put with
children at risk for asthma and other
allergies that was hypothesis and here's
the Vedic study design you can go find
this it was published in in the record
in the reference they're dictating
trials on clinical trials.gov it
involved basically giving women in the
treatment arm 4,000 units of vitamin D a
day and then the placebo arm women got
400 units
vitamin da day there were eight nearly
900 women three sites in this study and
you can see all the things that were
looked at on this study but again it was
as no list was the primary one and so
how did this come out it was published
in ultimately published in JAMA and the
results we thought were striking but
there but if you come back to how again
the standard medical profession views
this is it doesn't jive with Institute
of Medicine and to me is if you come up
with positive results it's not very well
liked okay they just don't want to see
it and so when when this data was was
was analyzed it was analyzing and intent
to treat there's always problems with
intent to treat there's a lot of
non-compliance of the subjects in no
different in in this particular group
and one subset of these individuals we
know we had greater than 50 percent
non-compliance which means those people
would be considered treated but we're
actually blue SIBO and when you come
right down to it given those numbers
it's it's it's ironic you know it's
incredible you see any effect whatsoever
however if you looked at this data how
the treatment affected the 25 D levels
and the mother is given four hundred and
four thousand you can see at enrollment
at enrollment the vitamin D levels were
15 animals or so and then at the third
trimester of treatment either four
hundred or four thousand it was
significantly higher in the mothers
given the four thousand although it's
approaching 40 the mean is approaching
about forty nanograms or so again where
where you want to be so it's not like
women getting ten times of vitamin B
have ten times the circulating 25 D it
just doesn't work that way and then if
you looked at one year after delivery
the levels are are pretty much the same
in the mothers now keep in mind that the
vitamin D was only given during the pre
a period after delivery no more
treatments were given and the patients
were followed and these are the levels
in the in the in the infants in the cord
blood again you can see that the klar
blood from the mothers who had taken
4000 units were higher than the 400
units it's not startlingly high it's a
significantly higher and then at year
one and year three they're equal which
would expect because there's no further
vitamin e treatment after after
pregnancy and after birth so what do we
find in this study okay what they found
was was you can see this graph of the
different rates of reduction but
basically what we found is the
development of asthma was lower in the
infants that got the mothers got 4,000
units versus 400 now this was assessed
in the infant's at one two and three
years okay at three years my intent to
treat the significance was 0.05 one at
the other points it was better than 0.05
or better to publish this paper the deal
was in JAMA that we had to state that
those were non significant studies
because it was point oh five one and not
0.05 zero the author's made a decision
to go with it hoping that the public
would see and make their own decisions
but it was put into the news as vitamin
D has no effect but not significant
effect on asthma generation which was
simply not true so in the jam of paper
year three vitamin D was demonstrated or
then again at 0.05 one they would have
been old five O or 0.049 it would have
had to say it was significant but JAMA
demand at the author state that the
study was therefore not significant
however okay this is a straight intent
to treat data and you have to that's
what drug trials use and there's all
sorts of problems that do nutritional
studies like vitamin D
because there's compounding factors
everybody has some vitamin D in their
blood how does that affect the final
results so if you take baseline levels
of the mother into account a very
different picture emerges and what do I
mean at baseline levels I mean the
levels that were those mothers had in
their circulation when they entered the
study probably owning up to the fact is
what those levels were were at
conception because they weren't taking
any vitamin D we hadn't given them
anything yet and these were lifestyles
okay of how people's vitamin DS be it's
son where they take it supplements but
what they were doing when they got so
how did that affect the outcome when we
looked at mother's first trimester
vitamin D levels profound okay here's
the effect in supplementation and the
odds ratios of the children developing
asthma if they entered into the study
the women entered into the study with
vitamin D levels of these are at the
bottom these are levels in the first
trimester of what these women were when
they came into the trials less than 20
20 to 30 30 to 40 greater 40 nanograms
per ml if they entered in with those
levels and will put on placebo treatment
there was maybe some protection it
wasn't very startling okay however if
they came into the trial with in the
green hair with these levels okay 20 if
they came in at less than 20 nanograms
who were put on 4,000 units not
protection was offered 20 to 30 more
protection 30 to 40 more protection and
greater than 40 basically in this study
eliminated the asthma and the children
at 3 years now we weren't allowed to
present that data in the original
publication because of violated intend
to treat but it was subsequently
published in but with the group in the
in Jackie Journal of Clinical allergy
and immunology which is a very respected
journal and
the results are totally different when
you look at it this way and and what
does this mean it means that you have to
look at what the vitamin D levels are at
conception and it's not as simple as
just giving vitamin D supplementation
during pregnancy if you would looked at
this trial and that this the the resort
on a very astounding there it's more
complicated and what this what this
means is there's there's development
going on right after conception and
probably in lung development that can't
be reversed later by vitamin D
supplementation and needs in these
studies and ironically there was another
RCT going on besides the first one here
us it was there was another one going on
normal tone yin and there was another
one going on in the cops act study they
were published at the same time they
both just missed significance they were
similar types of studies they were both
published the same time and what was
done later is the groups got together
and we analyze that data and putting the
data all together to increase the sample
size that paper is just going to appear
and press in PLoS ONE and when you do
that you come up with highly significant
even intent to treat studies so vitamin
D supplementation during pregnancy can
prevent asthma development as men wheeze
in the child at three years and we're
looking at six year data and again when
we presented its data that the combined
analysis to to JAMA they didn't even
review it they didn't want to hear about
it so it doesn't end up in JAMA doesn't
fit their narrative and so that's where
you go finally I want to move around
here secondary analysis of e dart we
want to look at preeclampsia preterm
birth based on the factors that we saw
how does vitamin D affect preeclampsia
in their preterm birth and if you this
was published
in in Journal of Clinical Investigation
within the last year or two and you can
search that out in PubMed and if you
look at this again how does it affect
preeclampsia well it comes it's similar
to asthma okay and if you look at the
paper
basically what low low means low low low
high high low and high high low low
means they came into pregnancy with with
less than 20 nanograms in the first
trimester said conception and they were
put on the low dose of vitamin D 400
units during pregnancy and that was the
odds ratio that was our baseline level
if they came in low at 20 we'll put on
the high dose they got some they got
some protection against preeclampsia if
they came in high and were put on the
low dose they still had significant
protection meaning that whatever was
happening in preeclampsia again a lot of
it was happening at conception or in the
first trimester which of course in our
studies we did we that we really missed
the first trimester and then if they put
him on high high meaning they came in at
40 nanograms and they went on the high
dose there was an incredible protection
against preeclampsia in these women
basically it was eliminated now let's go
to this slide that was published in in
the JCI paper and it was a risk for
preeclampsia based on on the bottom axis
of what the vitamin 25 D levels were at
conception basically first trimester and
if you look what what you won't see in
the paintin in this in the figure in the
journal and this figure is you won't see
the top the cases and controls they that
was they wouldn't allow that to be
published and basically what that shows
is the cases of preeclampsia at the top
versus the controls at the bottom if if
vitamin D at 14 anagrams okay if you
look at that offered
perfect protection against preeclampsia
meaning that if a woman came into
pregnancy with 40 nanograms or higher
they were completely protected against
preeclampsia
there's not one case out there and by
statistics alone there should have been
six or seven cases out there based on
how many people were out there and there
were none so and this this is a very
important study is that is that
preeclampsia is highly linked to early
vitamin D status in mothers and you can
again here was how the study was
conducted there was a lot of genetic
signatures in here it was in the in the
in the JCI paper you can go and read it
it's just too too involved to look at
here and these are the ten identified
gene sharing networks that we found in
the analysis of the JCI
basically involving gene clusters that
are in autoimmune disease inflammation
in infection these are the things that
vitamin D affects if you look at gene
clusters on basically any disease you
look at preeclampsia cancer they're
basically affecting the same gene
profiles so let's go to the next slide
again you can see this cobweb of gene
interactions from the preeclampsia that
were that were discussed and plotted by
gene array analysis in our preeclampsia
study and you can see the gene clusters
that are affected between our placebo
which is 400 units versus our treatment
which is 4000 so these are the genes
that are being altered by the vitamin D
supplementation during the pregnancy
period totally due to vitamin D
supplementation so the conclusions
mothers taking the current recommended
level of 400 IU's of vitamin D per day
will not provide adequate vitamin D this
is different actually a different paper
vitamin D intakes of 10,000 art art are
normal for treatment of physiology a
vitamin D is essential for pregnancy not
only for skeleton tegrity but awful
prevention of birth complications such
as preeclampsia development of childhood
asthma and scarier things like probably
neuro development this development of
autoimmune diseases such as type 1
diabetes and multiple sclerosis design
of vitamin D dosing your disease for
clinical trials based on normal
physiology and not convenience and
compliance and what I that mean is they
should be giving at a reasonable dosing
regime like daily no more in pregnancy
no nothing beyond weekly doses and the
levels given should be based on normal
physiology meaningful levels at four to
6,000 units and not 400 and I'll come
back again to the these studies were run
with incredibly tight monitoring
compliance and I've been involved in a
lot of these studies have been a lot of
dated monitoring boards were vitamin D
levels of thousands of units were given
to patients on various things of
pregnancy and I will tell you that we
are still looking for our first adverse
event due to vitamin D supplementation
we had a thousands of patients we have
not seen a single one and so the
paranoia about vitamin D supplementation
that these levels and adverse event
simply doesn't exist and I would say
that it's time for these etes monitoring
boards just to not function anymore
because when you're when you're looking
at trying to find an adverse event that
doesn't it's a total waste of money so
I'd like to thank everybody for
listening to this I know it was quite
involved and I'd like to answer any
questions that you might have thank you
thank you dr. Bruns hollered for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the green Q&A button at the lower lap
of the presentation window type your
questions into the box that appears on
your screen
and collect on the son budget what
answer is none of your question since
you have time flow let's get started our
first question is is vitamin D a mindful
during the prenatal or perinatal period
it is not harmful as I as I it is not
harmful as I showed in our introductory
material and these societies have to
have to get by this like the obstetrics
and gynecology and the one thing I
didn't mention in my in my presentation
is now here where I am at the Medical
University where these studies have
largely been performed over several
years now
it was find as a dis decision was
finally made here that all pregnant
women coming into the practice now all
get four thousand units a day all so the
the faculty and the fellows and and the
residents have all been instructed that
all women get four thousand units of
vitamin D a day I guess finally the
obstetrics Department at our own
University has seen enough data to
suggest that yes it is very beneficial
and there is no harm in in following
this practice and I'm quite proud of the
unit our University and obstetrics here
for instituting that practice
our next question is why are your
recommendations so vastly different than
there's currently recommended by many
professional societies okay okay again
I'll come back to the fact that the
recommend recommend aasaiya teas are way
backwards and the instant that very
paranoid about making recommendations
and vitamin D if it's not based on
skeletal integrity and you can see from
the data that we presented that it's far
beyond that and to prevent asthma and
preeclampsia and other things that I
didn't wasn't the focus of this talk
like prevention of cancer or the
prevention of autoimmune disease go way
beyond what it would be for skeletal
integrity but until the societies
recognize that fact not much from a
standpoint of official recommendations
is going to change and it's up to the
treating physicians and like this
continuum in continuing medical
education sessions for people to look at
the data synthesize that and make up
their own minds about how to best serve
their patients and that's basically the
point I wanted to make there
I would like to once again thank dr.
Bruce Hollis for his presentation I
would also like to thank lab roots for
making today's educational webcast
possible before we go I wanna let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing the
February of 2018 you'll receive an email
from laberd's letting you know when this
webcast will be available for replay
please shove an announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
loud bet it's all for now thank you for
joining us and we hope to see you again
soon
goodbye